A bomb goes off.
Then the familiar scenes of rescue, rubble,
and the dead, dying and wounded.
Another fatal day in Afghanistan.
Like on Monday: a suicide bombing in the capital
Kabul killed six people - nearly 100 more
were killed elsewhere around the country.
The United Nations estimates more than 8,000
people have been killed and wounded during
the first nine months of 2018 alone.
Still, the German government has not budged
on its deportation policy.
Afghan refugees can be sent back - against
their will, if necessary.
This, human rights groups strongly disagree
with - and are trying to stop.
In our view, Germany is violating international
law and the European Convention on Human Rights
by deporting people to Afghanistan.
That's because those laws prohibit deportation
to unsafe countries.
The German government, however, says parts
of Afghanistan are safe - even if the country
as a whole is not.
The government is more cautious when it comes
its own citizens visiting Afghanistan: Violence
affects "all parts" of the country, according
to the Foreign Office's long-standing travel
warning.
German authorities are tight-lipped when deportations
are carried out - often at night and out of
public view.
They declined to confirm the most recently
reported deportation flight, with federal
police telling DW only that a "repatriation
action" was in the works.
The Interior Ministry does not comment so
as "not to endanger the implementation and
success of a repatriation action."
Groups like Amnesty International want forced
repatriations to end.
We recently submitted to Interior Minister
Horst Seehofer a petition with nearly 30,000
signatures in Germany, demanding an end to
all deportations to Afghanistan.
The Interior Ministry has yet to respond to
the petition.